[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it is the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth uh do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am Jade warshaw your
host joined by John deloney Dr John
deloney on the ones and twos and today
we are taking calls about your life your
money your mental health so give us a
call the number is8 825
5225 and John today's a big day for
launch day launch day building a non
anxious life is out into the wild so if
you did not participate in the um are
bribing you to pre-order then it's at
every store you can imagine Target and
Barnes & Noble and Amazon everywhere go
pick it up it is uh it's pretty rad I'm
pretty excited how does that feel John
are you just like busting out of your
skin right now can I slap you just to
see if you're awake I mean you SLA me
all the time so you can do that again if
you want um no it's actually like a real
uh it's the next few weeks will be a lot
of nerves because it's out there yeah
and I can I can you know play the music
and beat the drum roll out but the proof
is in the pudding if somebody sits down
and dedicates some time to it which they
can never get back yeah that's the so
it's it's when people start saying all
right I need to have a hard conversation
with my husband or I got to figure out
how to reimagine my life with my kids
that's when it starts you go okay it hit
so it hit it hit now the nerves start
big time today there's no way this is
not going to hit John I'm so proud of
you I'm so excited for you I anybody who
has not yet picked up this book I am
telling you please go pick it up
building a non-anxious Life by John
deloney today is the dis it's out it's
out I'm so excited I hope that Andrea
Nashville Tennessee is equally as
excited about this book coming out
Andrea from Nashville what's going on
girl hi thanks for taking my call we're
doing good you're welcome what's
up um yes so um I have a question our
mortgage is more than that 25%
take-home um 25% within the take-home
pay that you recommend uhuh and so my
question is uh my husband started a
business a couple of years ago and his
income has doubled each year um so
that's great um so I'm wondering if you
think we should go ahead and get that
mortgage sell and get a mortgage within
that 25% number or if you think that we
should just hold off well what
percentage is
it it's more like 35% oo so yeah at at
the current rate and this is before his
income like what he's making right now
it's
35% correct how quickly how quickly do
you think with his income continuing to
go up how quickly do you think you could
get to a place where it's 30 at least 30
29 like how quickly do you think that
you can make that
transition I mean I think within the
next year he'll be at a point where it's
like probably in that 28 29 range and
then I feel like it will continue to
grow um it's just kind of tight on us at
the moment um we love where we live
though we live in negated neighborhood
that we feel really safe with our kids
and do you work so I do I do um so I
make I make about
120 um and he makes about
currently 75 and do you have room to
grow as
well yes yes I have room for um
promotion you know what if I'm you I'm
probably I'm going to stay put and but I
am going to put a cap on this because
you don't want to live strapped like
this for you know two and three years so
I'd probably put a cap and say hey in in
a year and a half in two years if we are
still like if we haven't seen the needle
move and if we haven't seen it move
significantly then we need to think
about getting out of this because right
now you probably don't have a lot of
margin to do the things that we would
teach you know are you able to invest
15% yeah so my company offers a 401k
match so I am contributing being up to
the match which is um which is a total
of 12% okay and then what about your
husband um he is currently not at the
moment as he works to grow the business
yeah I love the 12 I love the match that
you have it's excellent um we always
treat that as just icing on the cake we
want folks to get in the habit of using
their own money to invest 15% because
God forbid something happens maybe you
switch jobs maybe you go somewhere where
the perks you know aren't as is good we
want to make sure that you're building
that muscle if 15% of my income always
goes to retirement so for that reason
also the reason of you know right now
you guys are strapped with this mortgage
I would put a time frame on this um and
you can talk with your husband no more
than two years I wouldn't stay in this
situation for any more than two years
because I think that it has the ability
to play out in a lot of different ways
even in your relationship right John
when you live in your home and it's
taking up so much of your take-home pay
that's not
I mean it just creates frustration yeah
Andrea can I ask a personal
question yes you're I mean you're
calling for a reason and you went
looking for this plan and these ideas is
there that that I it's just that
underlying tension about money in the
home is that exist there or is this just
you guys everything's fine and wonderful
but you're just trying to play by
different set of rules
now well yes there's definitely a little
bit of tension you know I would love to
have extra wiggle room in the budget and
it's been a little stressful with him
starting the business for sure you know
I'm super proud of what he's done but it
has put a financial you know uncertainty
and strain a little bit on our
relationship absolutely and so what we
what we people fight us over the math of
it all what's a big deal to me is that a
husband and wife team don't wake up in
five years and this is just the way
their life is because
I've seen it over and over I've lived in
this world over and over you can only
take so much your physical body can only
take so much of that tension before you
start finding ways to take the edge off
that tension and it might be another
drink it might be a distraction it might
be just scrolling the day away it might
be someone at your office that laughs at
your jokes and he makes you feel special
and suddenly you're responding to texts
and flipping your phone over it just
slowly slowly starts happening that that
way when there's this constant burn in
the house underneath everything and
again your husband sounds like he yall
agreed on this he jumped with both feet
he's working his butt off he's got this
business up to 75 grand and he's got
potential to grow up more that doesn't
mean anybody's doing anything wrong but
I think what um Jade said is so
critical man going out for a long run
feels so good and training for something
is good but if you don't have a Finish
Line all of a sudden your body at some
point your body just says I quit that's
right you just start running and running
and running so I love the idea of y'all
sitting down saying we we want to have
more peace in our home if you come to
him and say hey you got to get right in
two years or um so we can get this under
25% or you're going to have to quit well
now he's got to fight you because you
just start a fight if you sit down and
say I'm willing to have an anxious
stressy home for a couple more years
because I see your vision and I see what
we're building together um but in 2
years we're going to have a hard
conversation about is this sustainable
for the life we want for our kidss and
it might mean we're going to move we're
going to keep the business it might mean
50 different things but let's put a
Finish Line to sit down and say have we
crossed that line yet are we there are
we safe do we feel good as a couple or
do we need to make some hard choices
about what comes next I love that that's
a that's a really great question that
you asked Andrea and I'm really glad
that you were thinking ahead um very
very good stuff you're listening to the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a 5,000
,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Church Hill gives
you an advantage over those other guys
go to Churchill mortgage.com today to
learn
[Music]
more
what's up guys you're listening to the
ramsy show I am Jade warshaw one of your
hosts for the day joined by Dr John
deloney who has a new book coming out
today building a non-anxious life make
sure you pick it up we would so
appreciate that I know John would um and
one other thing if you listen to the
show if you enjoy the Ramsay show if
it's done anything for you uh we would
Sur love it if you would like the show
on whatever platform you're looking you
know listening to you know there's a
little heart button you can like it or
love it uh you can subscribe on YouTube
you can smash that subscribe button
right uh you can share it with your
friends um whether that's via text
however you like to share it that does
so much um not only for the folks in
your community because you're sharing
something that's very valuable but it
also helps us as a a network um more and
more people get to listen to the show
and see it uh pop up as a suggestion for
them and that is really really important
and it's totally free John I mean do you
share like when you when you like
something do you hit the like button do
you leave a comment do you share it I'm
not a big commenter um but when I listen
to a podcast and it I think oh man my
buddy needs to hear this or this is a
good one for my wife to hear I'll
forward it to him and um that way we can
have a a joint conversation about the
same the same podcast so we can listen
to it which is awesome I love that or
I'll if I know people are going to be in
the car with me I'll have it on to where
it's kind of quiet and and then they'll
be like hey what is that I'm like oh
that that is the Ramsey show that's what
my brother did that's how I found out
about Dave Ramsey on the Ramsey shows he
had it playing in the car and uh shared
it with me and that was his median of
sharing it so yeah like subscribe share
it um we surely do appreciate that and
with that let's go to the phone lines
we've got Kate in Albany New York what's
going on in your world
Kate Hi there um so I I have a bit of
debt um and I kind of new to listening
to the Ramy show and I'm so glad that I
found it um hey welcome to the gang
welcome to the gang I know that's right
hey we're a weird crew and so we welcome
everybody we're glad you're here when
you say weird John are you just talking
about no all of it all of it very weird
but we're glad to have you we're glad to
have you what's up thank you so U my
husband and I had a bit of debt um I
would say he knows probably about 34 of
it um but he probably doesn't know the
amount of some of it um and having
listened to the show I know that I need
to tell him um but I definitely need to
get like a game plan in place um you
know from now through to retirement he
and I are both state workers in New York
um and that's like another question mark
too as far as like do we hold out for
that State retirement and stuff but we
need to take care of what is in front of
us first for sure okay big big question
here it sounds like you have some
hesitation to even bring this up to him
am I am I reading into of that
wrong a little bit just because um you
know we we've been together for 14 years
um and we are really good um you know
he's he's known about some of the debt
before we've you know kind of taken care
of it together um why do you feel like I
don't think sorry you keep saying he's
known about the debt um is it debt that
you're in crewing or is it that that
you're both in crewing and he's just
kind of mindless about it can you
explain that a little bit yeah so it's
debt that I'm kind of inre so and it's
kind of twofold um one of them is it's
credit card debt
um and does hey K does he
know about the credit card debt does he
know how bad it is he knows not totally
okay I'm just gonna be super honest with
you okay um yeah what I heard in your
voice when you started talking my mind
immediately went to
if you are having an affair have you
told him the truth about
everything and just a few minutes later
you say no I told him everything so this
conversation has been very much about
him about him about him about
him I think this conversation is very
much about y'all and very much about you
and it sounds like you're tired of not
being fully honest inside your own home
with the man you said I do with is that
right yeah yeah I would say that that's
accurate okay yep um what else are you
not telling
him um I mean that's that's kind of the
main thing is the credit card debt how
much is it you know it's probably
hovering around 15 right now okay is he
gonna be stun is he going to be all
Angry what's his response going to be I
think he'll be I think he'll be shocked
I think he'll be shocked I mean we have
good jobs like you know I I think hey I
don't care about that this is this is
about you've been keeping secrets and
there's a t
and he's felt that tension and here's my
promise he has thought in his own weird
New York guy way that that tension was
somehow his fault and he's probably been
trying to fix it for a long time in his
weird way well there might be another
side to that John you think here's
here's where Jade's brain goes and and
only Kate is going to know really where
it falls but I am I'm interested to what
sorts of things are being purchased
because here's the thing when I walk in
with a Target bag my husband's like
what' you get and I'm like oh yeah I got
this thing or I got this lamp or if I
walk in with the big shopping bag from
Zara he's like oh what'd you get ah so
are you hiding part of me that's
wondering is he not pay attention yeah
no he sees it he sees it coming in he
does for sure um we have two kids so I
do buy stuff for the kids um you know I
I he's seen the house fill up with
things he's seeing the house fill up
with things and he's also not asking
questions so there's there's some things
going on here joh yeah so I when you
talk about a game plan the only game
plan game plan I've seen work long term
is you to a change the environment you
got to get them out of your house and
you'll have to go somewhere and have
this conversation because it's going to
be a hard one and you have to say I
haven't been honest with you I haven't
cheated on you I'd get that out there
quick unless you have um no no but I
haven't been honest with you and I want
to come clean and I want us to get on
the same page and start getting safe
with our money
MH here's the truth and I think that's
the way to start and I think ask him I'm
going to ask you to stay with me on this
I know it's going to be a shock I know
you're going to get upset and you're
right to get upset I've hidden it from
you or maybe like Jade said maybe he
hasn't been a safe place to just come
home and say hey we the kids need some
stuff yeah and um so there's there maybe
there's two sides to all this but
somebody has to be courageous offsite
and go here's the truth we got to build
something new M now when I tell you that
what is your body instant response like
no way or that sounds amazing to have
that out in the honestly it's like a my
body's instant response is relief okay
perfect perfect that's awesome then I
want you to set that up this weekend um
and Jade can walk you through the actual
finances it feels like a million dollars
I don't think you have as much debt as
you think you do I think you have um it
feels like a million dollars I know it
does but I think it's the weight of the
lack of Integrity in your home that's
what's Weighing on you more than that
dollar amount yeah um is it just the 15
,000 or is there other debt laying
around as well there's other so what
else do you have so having watched the
show having watched the show I know
what's out there so um so there's about
15 in um credit card debt uhhuh there is
student loans that are about 30 okay um
there are two other unsecured loans that
are about 30 okay there is our cars
which call it 50 okay between the two of
them can you break those two down
separately for me car one and car two so
mine mine is about 21 and his is about
30 okay
um is that it or is there's there's
more uh we have a home equity loan okay
that we haven't spent all of yet um but
that when it's done it'll be about 40
and then our mortgage how much is the
mortgage so our mortgage we we have a
lot of Sweat Equity into our house um so
we owe about two 20 250 uh 220 okay uh
and if we were to sell it right now I
would think we could get at least 500
for it the reason I was asking about
that line of credit um or loan that you
have through the house is if it was more
than half I would save it for later but
since it's pretty low I'd add it in with
your debt snowball um which is what
you're going to do to attack this debt
now I'm looking at these vehicles if I'm
you do you do you offhand do you know
what they're
worth mine I'm upside down in
unfortunately I carried some negative
equity from the previous vehicle thought
that I was going to get out from under
it with getting something else and I
have not yet yeah if I'm you if I'm you
I'm looking at his vehicle I'm going to
try to get out of it I'm going to try to
get out of yours even if you're upside
down if you're upside down 5 or 6,000
I'm still probably going to take the hit
and do that you guys have got a lot to
work through John is right it's about
getting out of debt and it's about
holding each other accountable uh going
forward you're not going to get out of
this until you guys agree we're both in
this this debt is both of our issue and
we've got to change our behavior and
hold each other accountable to whatever
plan you guys decide to put in action
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey folks Dr John deloney here with
some great news new you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time they become Healthy
Habits Like choosing to slow down and
make time for a daily practice of prayer
and meditation one thing that has helped
me with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you 3 months free to get
started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Pao is giving you 90 days
free imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hall.com
Ramsey today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hall.com
[Music]
Ramsey
what's going on you are listening to the
Ramsey Show I am Jade warshaw joined by
the man the legend Dr John deloney with
a new book coming out today day it's
here man tell the folks about it John
building a non-anxious life if uh we
couldn't bribe you to buy it on pre it's
now in every store you can imagine and
you can find it at Target at Barnes &
Noble at books a million at on Amazon
wherever you buy books you can go to
john.com Ramy solutions.com no more
excuses and if you're sick and
tired of that burnout that always
stressed there's always electricity in
your house when you walk in to your home
the one place on planet Earth where you
should be able to drop your shoulders
and your bag and laugh drop drop your
bag drop your shoulders and say ah
welcome home but instead your body
tenses up this book's For You Go Get It
Go Get It Go Get It it's 20 bucks and
and probably cheaper other locations but
go pick it up and change your change
your family man so okay this is just for
me I read your previous book own your
past change your future um I've started
this book but I'm not all the way
through it yet how if you read that
first book how is this one totally
different uh basically that first book
is a
a it's almost a reverse engineering it's
a way to look back and say oh this is
why all this is happening in my life and
then at the end in on your past there's
a um there's a path there but it's more
esoteric it's more start considering
some things yes this book is a road map
step by step it is a blueprint so as in
West Texas the the farmer may say you're
want to head over Yonder that was on
your past this is waves on your phone
it's going going to get you exactly
where you need to go oh I love that
explanation love that it's almost like
baby steps right this this is the baby
steps for non-anxious life love that
love it love it well John I'm excited
for you I know it's going to go bananas
because that's just the kind of guy you
are so very very good well done let's go
to the phone Lin I'm bananas you I'm
just saying you're very good at what you
do is all I'm saying the people know
that though if you've ever listened to
the Dr John deloney show you already
know that John comes with the heat he
definitely knows his business so without
further Ado we will go to the phone
lines uh we've got Carlton in Detroit
Michigan what's going on
Carlton hey Jaden John how y'all doing
today we're we're partying that's right
what's up man Detroit Rock City amazing
I know I know I know we got the Lions is
everything going crazy going good right
now hey you know what you know what I'm
just gonna give you that one y'all need
a win y'all need a win I'm GNA give you
the Lions we need we need everyone and
we should be undefeated we're not GNA
get there we not not gonna go there yet
we all know what should happened so
we're gonna give you that one
congratulations man absolutely thank you
thank you all right so I'm a little
nervous but I'm curious um I got a
question so um I I got a I only have one
loan uh well one uh debt and that's my
car IE about just under uh 8,000 like
$7,800 okay and so I have about 4,000 my
check in and then I have another just
under like like three-ish in my
Robinhood account in my investments
single stocks and single stocks some
some kind of mutual funds but but um I
was wondering should I pretty much go
zero and pay this car loan off it's my
only one and I live at home at the
moment and I you know eventually want to
move out and stuff but I want to pay
this car off first and coincidentally I
I am like a car salesman now so that was
kind like yeah I deal with this every
day so I just I want to get mine done
for sure Carlton how old are you 24 24
all right I I love the way you're
thinking I'm right with you I'd be
wanting to get out of this house and I'd
be wanting to set myself up to make that
happen so that when you make that
transition you're in a good position
it's stressfree um so what I would do is
I would keep $1,000 aside um just as a
you know starter emergency fund just a
little cushion and and I would i' take
the other 6,000 and I'd put it towards
the car and pay the other 2,000 off
super fast you know cash flow from your
paycheck uh how much are you making from
your paychecks by the way each month so
I just kind of started this job so I
just started working pretty much for
Honda in April and I just got pretty
much let's say I just got the hang of it
just about a month ago I just had a
really decent month and I'm starting off
really nice as well so like it's it's
going good I'm expected to make you know
by next year at least by 80 to 80,000
maybe what was your decent month what
was your decent month last month my
decent month last month it was about
5,000 okay good good so you're getting
off hey that's not with interest rates
the way they have been there's a lot of
parked cars in those lots and so that's
that means you are are hustling which is
awesome yeah that's good so you got the
5,000 a month you're living at home this
month you'll be able to pay off the car
because you don't need $5,000 a month
when you don't have rent and you don't
have debt right so I think that you'll
be able to pay off this car tell me Tell
Me a Reason I might be wrong
but am I wrong just no you're not wrong
it's just I was wondering like yes
should I almost if I if I am making like
if I am was to make a little more money
should I hold off on can I save my Robin
Hood account pretty much I wouldn't
because nope I wouldn't because that's
not the way you should be that's not the
way I would advise you or that I myself
would invest to begin with cuz you're
just
and diing over there you're doing single
stocks what I really would want you to
do is open up a Roth IRA you know I'm
guessing do you have any benefits
through Honda yet uh well I do I I need
to look into that a little bit more but
yes I do okay well if they have a 401k
if they have a 401k eventually you know
we might look at investing there but the
first first things first and what I what
I laid out for you Carlton is our
framework but let me kind of put labels
on it so you understand what it is B
it's is a series of seven baby steps
that are ultimately going to get you not
only to debt freedom but like financial
peace right and wealth building so the
first baby step you get $1,000 saved
that's why I told you to set a $1,000
aside the second baby step is you pay
off all of your debt except your
mortgage so that's what we're doing by
clearing out your savings clearing out
your Robin Hood account and then after
that what you do is you build 3 to six
months of expenses in your case you're a
car salesman it's just you you're
thinking about moving out I would build
months of what you project will be your
basic expenses so go start doing the
research and say okay if I get an
apartment here's what the rent will be
and here's what I would need you know
for groceries basic groceries here's
what I need for basic gas here's what my
utilities are B you know and get that
Baseline of what you would need for six
months of expenses and after you pay off
this car that's what comes next and then
once you've done that you can start
going okay now what's it going to take
to move out I'm probably going to need
first and last month's rent right I'm
probably going to need I'm going to have
to get me a little U-Haul or you know
ask Uncle boo boo if I can borrow his
truck right we figure out what that is
what's it going to cost do I have to buy
him a pizza do I have to throw you know
vinmo him
$75 get all that listed out to find out
what it's going to cost and so we're
just walking down the line you finally
move out everything's good and settled
now you're on baby step 4 you've been at
your job for several months and now
you're going in there and you're saying
hey I think I heard you say I have a
401k I want to start investing 15% of my
paycheck into my 401k and that's how
this works and you're going to look up
in January of next year you're going to
be what is known as a responsible
financially literate adult and you're
going to be like man I'm killing the
game that's the plan that's the plan
I've been listening to you guys since
2020 so trying to been it been on and
off but yeah it's on now I want you to
get a Sharpie and I would tell you to
write this on your forearm but you
probably going to wear well maybe going
to wear long sleeves for the next few
months cuzz I want you to absorb this
okay you're going to get a
ton of what I call Bro wisdom it's going
to come from Instagram from Tik Tok
you're going to have people at the car
lot when youall just standing around
waiting for customers like you're not
you don't got to Rob you're crazy you
could be making here's what I want you
to stamp into your soul you're solving
for
Freedom
nobody is going to tell Carlton what to
do nobody Carlton will be owed by no one
not a car dealership not a mortgage
company not a student loan company and
when you get married when you start
having a
family Carlton will always be the
director of Carlton's life and so I John
me and my family me and my wife were
more than willing to concede a couple of
potential maybe percentage points in a
robinet account versus a savings account
long-term savings account because we
sleep at night because I don't want
nobody telling me what to do with my
life so we're going to solve for Freedom
Jay just gave you the path hang on the
line we're going to send you FPU as our
[Music]
gift well you've all played the
telephone game the first person Whispers
a message to the second person who
Whispers it to the third and so on
around the table until the original
message has completely changed multiply
that confusion by a 100 if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of ramsy we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netw Suite was the software we use
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us net week worked for ramsy and it
will make a difference for your business
too join the more than 34,000 customers
who trust netsuite to help make them
smarter and make better decisions and
level up their operations to to learn
more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramy
you are listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
Jade warshaw I am joined by Dr John
deloney and uh you can give us a call
the number is 88255 225 we'd be happy to
take your call and give us look we'll do
our best to advise you in the right
direction uh thanks for trusting us with
your issues by the way I think it's
something that you guys call in here and
ask about your life your money and your
mental health and they trust us of all
people John to to give him a little
guidance in the right direction I don't
know if I ever told you this but when I
first started my show I didn't know
anything about radio or any of this
stuff uhuh and um James was the uh
producer there bang up J job he was
doing too by the way um but I remember
the first few times people call yeah and
I would
say why why are you calling me and every
person answered the same hey man I got
nobody yeah and so at first I was cont
Tak a back and then I realized oh we've
created a very lonely world and um
people who just keep showing up on the
radio with the same voices and the same
consistent message and the same care and
the same love and the same willingness
to call Bull craap and we see it that's
the most trusted resource people have
these days and that's a it's an
indictment on our culture but it's also
man I'm happy that we're here well look
you got the letters to prove it though I
mean you got the stuff to back it up
let's be honest about that well I mean
you can you can back it up with letters
you can also back it up with experiences
can I mean's something all I have is
exper that's all I have is experience if
they had letters after like my financial
experience it would not be it would be
like Bo o zo like I I clowned finances
starting and now you know I understand
it you know when you come out of it so
thank you guys for trusting us and by
the way um if you are new to the ramsy
show uh there's several co-hosts you're
going to see a lot of people you know
move through these chairs we got George
camel and uh Ken Coleman Rachel Cruz
obviously Dave myself John we're always
switching through here and we all have
different expertises in different areas
and you're going to hear us talk about
all sorts of lingo you know baby steps
John's got the things that he talks
about uh we all speak kind of a a ramsy
ease around here and if you're not sure
what that is we want you to hop over uh
to ramsy solutions.com and you can click
the get started button and when you go
over there we're really just going to
give you your best next step we're going
to walk you through and say hey when we
we're going to look at your situation
and tell you exactly what your next step
is and you'll kind of learn the lingo
baby steps and gazelle intents and what
do we mean you know when we're talking
about uh mortgages and all these
different things so if you're looking
for that head over to Ramsey
solutions.com click the get started
button we're glad that you're hanging
here with us and uh the other day myself
and Ken Coleman who is our career coach
he's really into getting people into
work that matters we were in Washington
DC John yeah I saw that I was we were
just talking off break last week for you
was Nashville to New York City back to
Nashville back to wa I mean over to
Washington DC and then you're back like
day after day you've had it man dude
yeah it's good though shout out Sam for
keeping the fort down man look Sam was
keeping the fort down with these two
little kids these three three and five
years old they they had three Square
meals that's right you know they had
sunlight they did good surv that's right
but yeah U it me it was pretty rad to
see you and Ken out there and it was it
made such an impact we were talking
about it off the show wasn't just a bit
for us this is this was important for
everybody well yeah you know we've been
in a a student loan pause since 2020 so
three years people have gotten used to
having extra money in their pocket
having extra money in their budget which
it's a good thing because inflation has
been crazy interest rates have gone CRA
like it's so expensive to live you know
in American as an adult right now and so
everybody got used to this extra money
and now uh officially payments started
back with student loans on October 1st
and so we really wanted to be in the
place where it all went down uh on
October 1st and really just get on the
ground and see what people are saying
and it was such a good it was so good
yesterday we went live on the show and
so if you haven't seen it go back on
YouTube and watch that episode uh Ken
interviewed a congressman here from the
state of Tennessee live um and we just
gave our input on what we talked to what
we saw with folks and uh we did a lot of
man on the street interviews and I know
that James and the gurus back there are
going to drip out that information
as the time comes but it was really cool
you know I found John something that we
heard yesterday that was so interesting
is in this whole debate about
forgiveness right it's like America so
much wants things to be divided and
you're either for it or you're against
it and you know that kind of thing but
so many people that we talked to and by
the way they had no idea when we stopped
people on the streets they had no idea
that we were from ramsy Solutions you
know a money show they had no idea we
just said hey we love your opinion on
what you think about student loans and
so many people said you know this idea
of forgiveness yeah it would it would
have been cool like it it's always nice
the idea of Santa Claus coming and you
know dropping a present off in this case
you know forgiveness of loans but
everyone agreed that although that would
be nice it was kind of like a like
selfishly I would love this but I know
it's not good for the American people
it's not good for the economy it's not
good it's not a good precedent to set
going forward that this is what we do is
people get into trouble and we just
forgive their debt and by the way it's
not everybody it's just these small
group of people that we chose at this
moment everybody agreed that yeah that's
probably not the answer there's
something better so there's this
psychological construct it's an idea and
I I just it just left my head I think
it's called the abene Paradox um it's
somewhere around there but it's this
notion that when you get a group of
people together often the whole group
will end up making a decision that
nobody in the group wants because
everyone in the group thinks everyone
else is in for it and so you find out
throughout history people go along
with insane leaders right because they
think well I don't want to this leader
nuts but everyone keeps saying they're
great so I I'm I don't want to go along
and everybody starts going along with it
and I think similarly when somebody gets
up and goes I'm going to make all this
go away yes everybody knows we're going
to have to pay that off somehow MH and I
even borrowed money but I don't think
that's fair but yeah I don't want to be
the one and so suddenly the whole herd
heads in One Direction and no one in
that herd thinks it's the right
direction and everybody flies off a
cliff and there was something important
about this notion that if um from the
great n TB says if you see fraud and you
don't say fraud if you don't yell out
fraud you're a fraud oh complicit yeah
you have to be a part of saying this is
nuts and when you got back and um we
were talking earlier before the show
that's it actually makes me feel good me
too that people in the American public
isn't dumb no would it be nice of course
it would be but we have to start
speaking up yeah there's still that um
there's still that that true north there
where people go yeah but and they Circle
back around but is it right is it fair
no it's not and everybody was able to um
voice that but something else uh John
that came out of that which look we've
still got work to do here at Ramsey
because a lot of the folks I talk to I
said so do you think it's possible there
were two possibilities I asked do you
think it's possible to go to debt to go
to college without debt and do you think
it's possible if you have gotten into
debt do you really think it's possible
to pay it off and that part I was a
little sad at what people I mean the the
responses I got were pretty incredulous
it was like oh pay off the like I've
never even thought about paying it off
like well I mean it's going to take 20
years you know it was really this
thought that if you have student loan
debt it's going to take 20 25 years to
pay off if that if you ever get out and
uh you know on the show the point is
opening people's minds to the
possibility that you can actually do
hard things like it's not normal in
culture to just go out there and say
I've got $100,000 of debt I'm going just
pay it off I'm going to do the work for
two and a half years and pay it off
that's not normal and so it was
interesting talking to especially you
know young cats you know 18 19 20 21
years old and that had never even
entered their brain which means parents
aren't talking like that so what we're
doing here is Big work it's total
Paradigm Shift total mental shift and
letting people see that so there's
another psychological construct um the
idea is learned helplessness and there's
some old studies that they did with with
dogs and and I think ended up into some
other animals too but they would shock
the animal and of course they can't do
these experiments today but they would
shock the animal and there was no way
for the animal to get out and eventually
the animal accepts their fate and they
just there's a there's a visible
collapse well then they would move them
to somewhere else where there wasn't a
shock MH the animal wouldn't move it
just accepted this is the way things are
and I think that's why it's this show is
important and other voices out there
important cuz we have to give people
their power back they've just G come to
accept this is just the way this is and
it's not that's right it doesn't have to
be and we talked about this before John
but you guys listening you can do your
part by changing the conversation
around you when you talk about the fact
that you paid off debt when you talk
about the fact that you're sticking to a
budget when you talk about the fact that
in 2 years you're going to be debt free
it changes the conversation in the air
and it opens people's minds up to what's
possible keep talking America they're
listening this is the ramsy
show hey what's up guys it's Jade if you
love the show and want a deeper dive on
your money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
[Applause]
Newsletter live from the headquarters of
Ramsey Solutions it's the Ramsey show
where we help people build build wealth
uh do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships I am here
Jade warshaw joined next to Dr John
deloney and I hold in my hand a copy of
your new book John release day release
dat ah building a non-anxious life and I
must say the cover is quite flattering
pretty handsome not GNA lie not gonna
lie who is that Dave uh requires that we
have our faces on our books
and um those those digital editors back
there can do a number on on an ugly on
an ugly face and an ugly picture man
they're pretty amazing no dude this
looks great you just look directly at it
it's wonderful um building a non-anxious
life you had all this pre-sale hoopla
but today all that's over and today is d
day that's it and now you just hang on
and um hope it connects like you like
like you hoped it would oh it will I
have no I have no worries about that
John it's awesome man uh your writing is
spect spacular and I'm excited about it
uh happy to know you if I'm honest happy
to know you and Sam too man well let's
take some calls the number Isle 8825
5225 we'll go directly to the phone
lines we got chrisy in Sarasota Florida
what's going on
chrisy I'm so excited to talk to you
guys we're excited to talk to you I just
have to say I just have to say you guys
are my favorite Duo don't tell anybody
right we're going to tell everyone
especially
Ken I'm so excited and I just can't
awesome all right so go for it what's
up so okay I'm wondering if I should
which I think I know the answer but I'm
wondering if I should go into debt to
prioritize my health so I'm not dying I
just got a diagnosis of polycystic
ovarian syndrome and that has the
potential to affect my fertility I'm not
trying to have kids yet I'm just trying
to be proactive so that once I do try to
have kids I don't have any issues when I
knew there was a problem I could have
prevented so the um treatment that I
want to do is $ 3900 paid in full and I
checked before I was like I see you use
a firm is there interest and they were
like no but it's a $600 payment that you
have to make to qualify for zero
interest um and so I have only $177,800
in debt student loan debt that's it um
and then of course our house we did the
whole thing we sold the cars we sold the
guns we had a garage sale like my
husband and I went really really hard um
to get some of that taken care of um and
so we're committed and I'm I ask myself
all the time because I don't get to call
you guys every day what would what would
the the Ramsey personality say to me
yeah
and my thought is that okay I'm not
dying prioritize your health in the ways
that you can in kids are important to
you yes of course yeah um look okay so
you've got the 17 you got almost
$188,000 in student loan debt do you
have other debt laying around no okay
what do you guys earn what's your
combined
income so our combined income we do we
do own a house and we only have a,
emergency found that was a mistake but
whatever um well you're walking through
the baby steps so I get it okay right we
earn so I earn 4 seven my husband earns
68 so next we take home we take home
about like 7,000 a month which is
awesome okay and then we have two um
18-year-old girls that were kind of
mentoring and helping um living with us
so um Elizabeth who has kind of like
become like almost like a surrogate
daughter is paying 400 and then the
other Elizabeth is paying 900 a month so
they pay you 4900 okay yes so we're
taking home almost uh300 a month yeah
okay um so here's what I would do simply
and you tell me I'm going to tell you
what I think the solution is and you
tell me why you think it won't work or
why you think it will work um I would
pause the debt snowball and I would save
up for this procedure and I pay cash for
it right now yeah today this
month okay because this is not just
about kids this is a complicated thing
and you know I'm sure you went down the
Google rabbit
hole no I didn't you did it good for you
wow I I did some research I was like
okay cuz when I got the diagnosis I was
like are they sure like I was like did
they get because I had no symptoms I was
so confused I don't have um painful
Cycles like I I'm a very healthy person
and so I was like really um and so I did
some research and then I just went to my
doctor and I was like what the heck's
going on she kind of shut me down and
that's why why I want to go like the
naturopathic route yeah because I'm like
I don't feel respected well I I would I
would get a second medical opinion
before I did that okay so I'm I'm
talking to you like I would talk to my
sister you do whatever you want to do
okay um if you're my sister and you
called me and said hey my doctor won't
listen to me shut me down I would say
cool they've cashed out um not that your
doctor isn't right and you're wrong I
think we have a culture now that goes to
YouTube first and then challenges
somebody with with a medical degree and
we're like you're like
I I have buddies that are Physicians and
they're dealing with this all the time
but I also know there's a shutdown
you're stupid and I'm not and I'm not
having that either right so I would make
an appointment and get a second
opinion um this is a a procedure that
often when they go looking it might not
be nearly as bad as the um as the um
MRIs would suggest or it can be
infinitely more complicated and so I
think saving up for that procedure like
Jade said just pause The Babys this is
your health and this is kids is one part
of this but this is systemic man and you
this is about you being healthy in a
bunch of bunch of ways not just having
kids one day so I'd go get that checked
out how does thises
you sorry how does it how's what John
and I saying is it hitting right do you
feel like yes yeah so it's not it's not
a procedure it's just it's me it's
really hormone test
and then deciding how I'm going to be
eating differently based on that hormone
testing I would do a lot of research
before you go down that road okay and I
am dude I I have sat an arguments with
my medical doctor researcher buddies and
we have gone round and round and round
and round and there is a lot and it
pains me to say this because this was my
entire identity there's a lot of snake
oil out there there's a lot of right
stuff and hormone testing is critically
important but okay um sometimes a
medical doctor is wrong and sometimes a
medical doctor will shut you down
because they hear it 5,000 times a day
because people Google too much stuff
right that's where a second opinion is
going to be super important and being
honest with your physician and saying
here's what I'm thinking about
doing and please don't shut me down but
I'm scared about this other this other
path um and go that route but
$3,900 for some
specialized essential oil testing is is
messy and I know I just made everybody
mad sorry James the mean comments are
going to come um hormone testing is
important it's it's good but man look I
and and just for anybody listening if
you want to have a baby you can pause
the baby steps whether it's fertility
treatments whether it's adoption and
you've got to save up it's okay you
don't have to be debt free before you
have a family and I just want to say
that loud and clear some people it's
their personal choice if they want to
hold off on a family and pay off their
debt first but hear me loud and clear
that's personal choice we are never
going to shake our finger at you for a
pausing paying off debt to have a baby
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something is
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com
rules and restrictions May
[Music]
apply this is the Ramsey Show I am Jade
warshaw he is John deloney we're taking
your calls all afternoon uh8 825 5225 is
the number John uh king Coleman and I
were in DC yesterday and two days prior
to as well getting a feel for how
everyone was feeling about student loans
coming back online October 1st was uh
dday uh Dave was calling it Sunday
Bloody Sunday which I thought was funny
but uh the whole idea is student loan
payments were restarting with interest
and so we went to see how folks were
feeling about that and um it's
interesting you know there's been so
many different narratives going around
well maybe the government will come you
know forgive them maybe that'll be the
way out maybe some legislation will be
passed and there'll be caps put in place
uh maybe they should stop making the
loans altogether and so there's a lot of
a lot of thought and a lot of uh
different opinions about this but Yahoo
finance published an article that said
the US government's biggest financial
asset John is student loan debt I'm
going to say that again the US
government's biggest financial asset is
student loan debt and I mean big time
like over 1.1 trillion it says the value
of federally backed student loans held
by the government has risen by more than
a
th% since the last recession and now
tops at 1.1 trillion and if you're
watching on YouTube you can look at this
graph here student loans make up
45% 45% it says we hear a lot about
government debt but what we don't hear
about are government assets and so we're
looking at this and the Federal Reserves
Financial account data found that the
student loans make up the largest
financial asset held by the federal
government by a huge margin so I say all
that to say if we're waiting around for
the government to do something in the
way of maybe not making loans maybe
forgiving your loans anything that's
going to cause this to not be an asset
I think that we're going to be waiting
until the cows come home is basically
what I'm saying hell's basically going
to have to freeze over before that takes
place and then and I'm saying that
because here's I'm I want to light a
fear under people's butt right now a
fire and a fear to go hey I can't just
be willy-nilly about this like I can't
lolly gag with my student loans any
longer I've got to come up with a plan
to pay them off because hold on a second
before before we transition to that I
want to make sure everybody knows what
you just said cuz you used a fancy finan
where called asset and I may not have
known what that was yes what we're
saying is or what what that report is
saying is the US government's emergency
fund is your student loan payment yeah
the US government what was it 40% was
45% put that against um throw that throw
that graph back up there yeah against
how much cash it has yeah this is so to
put in to put in perspective total
mortgages like when you have a mortgage
to the federal government 4.6% % if we
have the currency checkable deposits and
currency 11.1% so cash yeah other loans
in advances so miscellaneous loans in
advances 7.7% and the government will
make loans to other countries to help
them out with you know food shortages
and things like that yep but 45% taxes
taxes receivable 16.4% student loans 45%
wo so what we're saying is almost 50% of
the business
of the US government the cash that runs
the machine that is your roads that is
your FBI that is your government that
pays the salaries of your congressman
and women is student loan repayment yeah
it will not go away because it's the
half of the economic engine if that goes
away or it's not half the economic
engine is half the assets yeah that's a
mess that a scary scary place to be so I
say that to set the stage for this idea
if you're waiting for these to go away
they're not going anywhere and not only
are they not going anywhere but if you
don't pay the piper you're on the hook
for some serious uh business here we
actually at Ramsey Solutions we put out
articles all the time about uh topics
that are important to you guys um and we
recently put out a topic that said what
happens if you don't pay your student
loans because I know I'm getting up in
folks grill right now but I know there's
a lot of you who have just decided I'm
not going to pay it that's okay I'm just
not going to pay it and let me tell you
why that's a terrible idea number one we
just said because they're going to keep
making them and number two it says uh
federal student loans owned by the US
Department of Education and Federal Loan
servicers have the power they have the
full power of the government behind them
to get this money from you of course
they do and they're not going to sleep
on that because we need the money as
we've just explained so if you decide
that you're not going to pay your loans
let's walk through a couple of the
things that can happen to your butt
number one if your loans be your loan
will become delinquent immediately after
you miss a payment so if you mess around
in October and you're like you know what
I'm not ready I'm just not going to pay
it uh you'll be delinquent and you can
you will be charged a late fee up to 6%
of the monthly payment that's crazy so
add that to the interest late fees
terrible next thing it says uh your loan
service will then report your student
loan as delinquent and if that goes on
for more than 90 days of course they're
going to report it to Experian uh
Equifax TransUnion that's your credit
report so now it's going to start to
tank your credit score if you keep
letting it go on past that it goes into
default um and this usually happens
after about 9 months of Miss payment so
you're totally in default okay and once
your loan gets into default so once
you've gone about 9 months without
paying your loan here's what will happen
your entire amount your so let's say you
owe $80,000 the entire amount becomes
due
that's called loan acceleration and it's
a very real thing and it's a very scary
thing so if you think that you're going
to mess around and just willy-nilly like
I'm not going to pay it they they can't
make me you're getting into some really
serious water here if that happens at
this point you're in default and it's
reported again to the Credit Agencies
but if even if you wanted to apply for
deferment forbearance you can't at that
point you've already proven you can't be
trusted you're no longer eligible for
any of the income-driven payment replans
right payment repayment plans so if
after you know being delinquent for 90
days finally decide for N 9 months you
decide oh you know I think I'll do the
save plan no you can't do it or I think
I'll jump into one of these idrs you
can't do it okay you won't be able to
apply for any more financial aid which
that's probably the only Silver Lining
here is you can't go further into debt
by applying for more student loans if
you go this far down the road which is
good um but here's here's the kicker
it's the federal government and uh they
can re reach their old Winnie the Poo
paw into your Honey Jar called your bank
account and they can garnish your wages
uh they can take your Social Security
they can take your tax refund they can
take your passport many people say no
they can't no they can't how how would
they get it remember when um I think it
both the Trump Administration and the
bid Administration wrote checks for coid
and they magically appeared in our
checking accounts direct deposit that
means it can come out also now this is
talking about garnishing it from your
check that your check's just going to be
hundreds and hundreds of dollars lighter
yeah but I think there's a step past
that y'all they have proven in the last
few years they have the technology to
just put stuff in your account which
means they can just take it get out yeah
when you wake up and you're like wait a
second I'm supposed to have $3,000 why
do I only have 200 or zero and you're
looking like Will Smith in the pursuit
of happiness the problem is they just
went into your account and they took
your money because you owed it and you
decided not to pay and so this can get
very seriously very quickly and I hear I
hear uh naysayers in the background John
sometimes I can hear the peanut gallery
you know throwing peanuts at me even
here on the on the air and I hear
somebody going but Jade I'm doing the
the 12mon
onramp I don't have to pay it I'm doing
the 12mon onramp and what that is is in
a stroke of Genius Biden has said hey
for 12 months if you're not ready to pay
you don't have to pay and we won't
report it to the credit card companies
we won't uh count you as delinquent and
a lot of people are thinking hip hip
hoay that's great but what will happen
is you're still going to be charged
interest and so your balance is going to
continue to go up guys you can run but
you can't hide when you sign your L your
name on the dotted line you owe the
money and there is nobody coming to save
you not when the student loan industry
is making up 45%
of us assets they ain't going anywhere
you're going to have to pay the debt and
we want to help you pay the debt we're
not saying this to get on to you we want
to help you there is a way
out that's all I got to say there's a
way
out this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
what is going on everybody you are
listening to the Ramsey show my name is
Jade warshaw I'm your host today joined
by your other host today Dr John deloney
um I'm here to talk about the money
stuff John is here to talk about the m
mental health and wellness stuff but he
knows the money stuff too let's be
honest about that John that's right and
if you want to talk about both money and
your relationship our first ever money
and marriage get getaway how's that for
a uh roll into a
commercial James does James approve
October 19th through 21st money and
marriage getaway our first ever marriage
Retreat you and your spouse will be
equipped with tools to cast a vision for
your family set goals and create a life
you both love you're going to have
undistracted time to disconnect from
everyday life reconnect with your spouse
we're going be talking about money
intimacy and sex communication
boundaries all of it tickets are 799
bucks for this multi-day event there's
going to be a party it's going to be so
fun it's going to be a blast if you're
out of debt and you got room in the
budget we want to see you ramsy
solutions.com
events there just a few tables left make
it a weekend get away and come see us oh
yeah I'm excited about that I'll be
there too myself and George C be
thinking of that too that's going to be
fantastic speaking is a fluid term John
I I'm going to be doing a thing oh a
thing you'll have to show up to see what
it is but it's musical you know it's
going to be a good weekend when they're
hiding stuff from yeah it's it's awesome
I can't wait it's good all right let's
go to the phone lines John we got Molly
and Hartford connect I cut what's going
on
Molly hey guys excited to be talking to
you thanks for having me on you're
welcome good to hear from you what can
we do to help yeah so I just wanted to
kind of organize my thought with you
guys um my fiance and I um have been uh
really tuned in to you guys I've started
I know i' probably came up up up with a
um Instagram video and um things just
really started to click I've been
listening to you guys every day and
we're just really on board and excited
about getting our debt paid off so um I
have about
$120,000 uh in student loans I have a
master's degree clinical social worker
my fiance has about
15,000 um it's car credit card and
personal
loans um we have a combined income of uh
157 um
$157,000 so we just wanted to get our
ducks in a row and start to tackle this
because we want to buy a house and
that's not happening with all this debt
so when are you guys getting married
we may of next year May of next year
okay sorry I missed that last part can
you say it again speak directly into
your phone yep yep May 2024 okay sweet
um I'll hop in and tackle the first part
um Molly so I'm telling you this not to
put bad vibes out in the air but only
because we what we do for a living we
hear the other side of the story so so
often
okay until y'all get married oh yeah I
have his debt and have yourb yes um
because you don't want very aligned in
that good you don't you don't want to
start working on your debt something
side goes sideways heaven forbid it goes
sideways but it goes
sideways and now you're in a legal mess
there's not there's not as much legal
protection as um if you get married
there's there's ways to untangle things
as awful as that is to think about um
everybody's got a path out whereas when
you break up it's just a mess um okay go
ahead so so I want to make sure I
understood you clearly about the debt
you've got 128,000 in student loans I
thought I heard you say your fiance has
15,000 in student loans but then you
listed out cars and personal loans as
well yeah I don't know if I said that
wrong sorry so he just has the 15,000
and that's car credit cards and personal
he does not have any student I'm the
only one with student long okay so you
guys are about like 143,000 in debt and
you'll be making 157,000 so to John's
point I agree you're keeping it separate
and the plan is this until you both get
married you're both working the baby
steps as
individuals and more than that yeah
you're doing that but the conversations
that are having that you're having
during this time are really going to set
you up um those expectations of what you
expect the accountability levels all of
those things are good to start having
those conversations now so you can kind
of start to see what each other's
identity is as it relates to money
because you might hear Dave talk about
you know the nerd and the free spirit
and things like that and there's a lot
of that Nuance um when you come into a
new relationship I can tell you when my
husband and I got married I don't I
didn't like a lot of um I didn't like
anybody telling me how to spend I'm just
going to be honest I didn't like that
and it made me feel trapped or it made
me feel like I don't know like I was
getting in trouble you know when
somebody says hey you know make sure you
check the account before you spend so
understanding those nuances between each
other having those
conversations starting today really is
going to help you going in um explaining
hey if you're going to ask me if we're
going to talk about money you know here
here are the tones that trigger me and
here's why like just talking about that
as much as possible um going in is going
to be super helpful kind of
understanding each other's background as
it relates to money and why you think
about it the way you think about matters
so so much so I don't know have you had
conversations like that at all oh yeah
yeah so when I started this I kind of
brought it to his attention like hey
I've been listening to this guy Dave r
and I just feel like I woke up like and
I my head came out of this standand and
I'm like holy like I've been um you
know with the student loans not paying
anything but you can't go back in time
right like it is what it is um I um on
Friday had an interview for Private
Practice I'm going to be doing a
part-time job utilizing my degree and
making some extra money and all of that
is going to get thrown at the loan every
month so I'm excited I'm motivated what
do you make what do you make every month
do as a clinical social worker
so my um what is it it's 60 67 a year
golly are are you have you finished your
ler yet I'm not fully licensed I'm lmsw
so uh licensed Master okay and I have
all my hours completed and everything I
just need to take the test okay um I
lost my mom a year and a half ago to
brain cancer so there's just been a lot
going on um so trying to just get back
into the swing of things um and just
yeah feeling you guys definitely
motivated me and uh were excited I want
to jump to my next question let me let
me tell let me tell you one thing real
quick um what I'm seeing um across the
country right now because you're not
alone and being a mental health
practitioner and graduating with a whole
whole lot of student loans that if you
look at the actual cost uh I mean the
actual Roi on that it's it's not
great um I would consider consider
strongly looking outside your
traditional scope of practice what does
that mean possibly getting a job as the
head of Resident Life at a um local
University looking at other positions
that are going to pay significantly more
money um for the skill set of a social
worker I can think of very few jobs
outside of precision technical stuff
that would not benefit from having the
training you went through as a social
worker it would be an amazing addition
to any number of businesses as a project
manager as any number of things but I
want you to consider working outside
your field especially while you're
paying all this debt off I don't want
you making
$67,000 trying to dig out of a
$130,000 hole because what's going to
happen is in two or three years you're
going to resent your clients and you're
going to resent the fact that you got
this job you're going to go to work
every day frustrated and be down and I
don't want that for any of y'all in that
ecosystem okay so do what you can to get
out of this thing as quickly as possible
yeah second that notion so you said you
had a second question yeah I just so
we've been like I said diving in
understanding all this and I just want
to wrap my head around the concept the
no credit card concept and and having
credit so my fiance and I we are renting
right now but when we think about buying
in the future if you're not utilizing
the credit cards when are out of debt
how do you buy a house without having
credit absolutely what does that look
like yeah that's such a good question
and we get it all the time um and it's a
great question you don't need credit if
you're going to do manual underwriting
which we have Churchill Mortgage to help
you with that um it's it's a mortgage
company that looks at your actual money
and how you're managing your actual
money it works a lot like a normal
mortgage process it's just more detailed
and at the end of the day you're going
to actually get a house that you can
afford they're got not going to loan you
more money than what you can actually
handle so uh stay on the line and uh
Austin will pick up and give you more
information about that but yeah America
it turns out you don't need a credit
score not even to buy a house this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumps
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
you are listening to the ramsy show my
name is Jade warshaw I am your host uh
but not the only host next to me is Dr
John deloney and we will be taking your
calls we'll chop it up with you give us
a call the number is 8825 5225 anything
you want to talk about uh your life your
money real quickly um we had a call
earlier where the lady was talking about
John uh credit and is it really possible
to exist in the world without a credit
score is it really possible um to buy a
home without a credit score and I kind
of wanted to take a moment because I
know people have that question it's like
okay I'm paying off all my debt I've
said no more to debt and the reality is
when you start walking through baby step
two which is paying off all of your debt
except the mortgage when you start
walking through that process you most
likely will start to see your credit
score go down um and it goes down before
it goes to zero or
indeterminable and as that happens you
do kind of have this moment of oh crap
like I'm in it now and I'm I have to
fully commit to this because you see
that Avalanche happen and you're like oh
wait a minute everything that Society
told you to work for like this you know
800 credit score and you see it start to
go down and it and it does do something
to you psychologically and then you go
oh wait I don't need it anyway it
doesn't matter at all yeah it was a
light bulb moment for me Dave and I were
having a conversation off air one time
and I realized oh wait a minute Dave if
you just gave me a million dollars in
cash that would not affect my credit
score has nothing to do with how much
money I am how wealthy I am how well I'm
doing it has to do with my dating
relationship to a woman named Dad yeah
that's it how much how much of it you
use how much debt you use how much debt
you have
uh how long you've had your debt how
many lines of debt like it's debt debt
debt debt debt debt debt that's it so
think of it this way what if um I don't
know what's one of the apps that like
the swipe right apps Tinder let's say
Tinder Tinder has a datability score and
the whole country is obsessed with
making sure you have a great datability
score and then you get
married and they're like well if you
don't keep logging in here your
dateability score is going to go down
like what do I care I don't care I'm
married like I've committed to this
person very similar thing oh that's such
a good analogy it like the debt people
like if you if you don't keep borrowing
from us we're going to we're going to
take your number down and we're going to
give you a zero we all remember getting
in trouble when we got zeros so we don't
want a zero it's like I just I'm just
I'm just out of this game yeah I'm not
playing this game with y'all anymore and
the bank wants your money the mortgage
company wants your money and so they're
going to ask for a couple more pieces of
paper and a couple more bills and
they're going to go oh you're super
doing great you're actually responsible
come on in and I love that you framed it
up like that because at the end of the
day this whole game is set up on the
idea that you can't make it on your own
you're too stupid you're too broke
you're too poor you can't make it on
your own you need us and so we're going
to score you based on only
us which is crazy and so the the young
lady who called in she was like you know
we're we're doing this plan you know
we're committed but what happens when
it's time to buy a house and I was
telling her yeah so when the time comes
your credit score goes to zero and if
you want to buy a house you 100% can I'm
telling you that because I did it I know
John you did it I bought a house George
just bought one George did with zero
with credit score of zero my score
wasn't zero but his was zero and yeah
mine was Zero took took some extra paper
yeah and again sometimes I hear the
peanut gallery they're like well of
course you guys did you work for ramsy
I'm sure you just went in there and they
did it for you no I did it before I
worked for Ramsay so T normal people can
just go in there and you get a manually
it's a manual underwriting manual means
you do the work like there's no
automation there right so it means they
get all of your paperwork they want to
actually see your if you have a small
business they want to see a t your tax
returns they want to see uh your pay
stubs they want to see what you're
earning they want to see if you've been
earning that for a while they want to
see all of your actual numbers and
actual money not just relationship to
debt and then they're going to say okay
based on this you know here's the
mortgage that you qualify for and for me
John I think that's I have way more um
that makes me feel way better than a
rocket mortgage that you can do during
halftime at the football game and just
type in your stuff oh I got approved
they don't know they don't know what
money you don't have why would I ever
want to get approved for a rocket
mortgage they'll loan you as m i mean a
monkey could do that like anybody could
just go what you put your name and your
Social Security number approved like
basically that's all on your credit see
what you owe yeah but with yeah with no
credit it's absolutely possible not only
is it I almost hate to say the word
possible because that makes people think
that there's part of it that might not
be possible it's normal like it's not
just possible it's it is what it is like
it's normal it's an everyday thing you
can just go and do it the problem is
nobody talks about it we're probably the
only people out there talking about
getting a zero credit score mortgage
with manual underwriting but it does
exist matter of fact Church Hill
mortgage is one of the companies that we
use
for that and that we're always going to
put towards you and I love church Home
Mortgage they've been amazing we've
bought two houses through them and
that's the way this thing works guys
when you commit to the process this is
how it works you're committing it's like
it's like John said you're married I'm
I'm I'm opting out of the game opt out I
always want to go back to Sol for
Freedom I'm not going to let
some thirdparty company or three
three-party companies tell me my
worthiness yeah I'm not going to cash
out my integrity and cash out my
autonomy to people I don't know saying
well we've run the numbers you're a
640 I'm just not going to play the game
not going to play the game and by the
way it took me and my wife a decade took
a long time to to scratch and Claw and
fall down and fail and take out another
stupid loan and have to get back on the
wag took a long time it's not like oh
must be nice no no no no like we got a
lot of blood in the street on this one
mhm but man and usually when you and and
for those listening usually when you pay
off that last debt like you owe nobody
anything else it usually takes about a
year or yeah about 12 months to see your
credit score go down to absolute zero if
you completely stop borrowing money and
here's the thing if you dilly dally with
this and you're like I'm going to keep
that one credit card open it's never
going to go to zero you're just going to
have a bad credit score and then when
you try to go buy a house you're going
to run into problems because it's got to
be good or it's got to be zero it can't
be yeah but I'm going to keep this
credit card open and then you're going
to end up with a four you know 420
credit score and you're not going to be
able to get anything so it's all or
nothing on this and John just to keep it
just to keep it 100% real like let's
let's shoot people straight on this
what's the what have you run
into in real life having a no credit
like what have you run into any
difficulties have you ever come up on a
a time where it's like oh these people
are jacking me because I don't have crit
like have you ever had anything that
it's like uh the only thing that's ever
happened to me is I one time and I
travel a lot mhm I went to um rent a car
yeah and they were annoying about it and
I literally walked away from that
counter and I walked into another room
and said will you guys take my money I
have an ATM card and they were or debit
card and they're like I started laughing
and within four minutes I had a car and
they're like see you later and so that's
the one time the one time yeah I'd agree
I I I remember one time I did get
charged I it was a rental car and they
they gave me issues and I think in the
end they ended up almost doing like a
like a deposit times two to hold it
gotcha and it's like okay yeah so
whatever I have the money um and so I
would say that when you do go to zero
credit score no credit cards that's
probably the extent of it you know maybe
when you go to buy an apartment because
a lot of times they want to check your
credit for an apartment bought i b you
know what I bought some kayaks this
summer for me and my family and I'd to
call my bank and let them know I'm about
to make a big swipe on this debit card
just so you all know and um they were
like great but I mean it was a phone
call I mean exactly look when we went to
buy our cat our car in cash that gave me
a little bit of a hassle because you
know they get they get a kickback on the
financing and it was to the point where
they were like you could just finance a
thousand of it even you know and pay it
off and I was like No And then when I
finally wrote them the check they you
know it was like they're just running
around like we don't know what to do
with this check can we cash it we have
to call your bank like they made it the
most they made it seem like the most
difficult process ever all in an in an
attempt to make me change my mind so a
lot of it's just hoopla because there's
money on the other side of financing
there's money on the other side of debt
and they want that but the key is don't
be swayed by that when you walk in you
know the power of money there's power in
Cold Hard Cash when you just slide it on
over if a company doesn't want to take
my cash then that's great you'll have a
great week I'm going to go do business
somewhere else that's fine I know that's
right I'm I'm not going to lose a second
of sleep over it I'm going to on Man Too
Short it turns out that you can exist in
the world today with actual money who
knew that does it for this hour of the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey it's Dr John deloney if you
love the show and want a deeper dive on
your money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the ramsy way just go to Ramy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter live from the headquarters of
Ramsey Solutions it's the Ramsey show uh
where we help people build wealth we
help them do work that they love and
build actual amazing relationships I am
your host Jade warshaw I'm joined by Dr
John delone and we are taking your calls
all hour I'll give us a call the number
is there 8825 5225 I've been saying it
for the last 3 hours and I'm going to
keep saying it John your book it's out
into the wild today we've let it out of
the cage that's right so I'm really
excited the book is called building a
non-anxious life and uh it's been on
pre-sale for the past several weeks and
now it's just it's out there and all
it's glory and you're just going to have
to buy it in all its Glory where can
they get the book John anywhere you buy
books you can go to ramsy solutions.com
john.com but also Target and Barnes &
Noble and books a million and Amazon
everywhere that I'm shook did you go see
it in Target can you go see it I haven't
been there yet we're going to we're
going to swing by and go take some
pictures just cuz it's surreal right
it's weird I'm going to go do that and
it's my face no I'm looking forward to
it it's good I'm I'm excited about this
I think it's going to help lots and lots
of folks you should feel very very proud
John thank you awesome uh well we are
taking calls um I'm kind of the money
person here today and John is the mental
health and wellness and he knows the
money stuff as well so give us a call
we'd be happy to help you out in the
meantime we're going to go to Amanda
she's in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania what's
going on
Amanda hi Jaden John Dr John it's nice
to meet it's nice to talk to you guys um
big fan of the show um I had a call
regarding um an adult child uh coming
back to live at home um our oldest son
um did some time in the military came
home after about five years no issues
with any like PTSD or anything like that
um but he's been home now for about six
months and we know we knew that he was
in a good bit of debt when he came home
so we told him you know um just take
some time get your life together get
some things established um and then just
kind of create a plan as to what you
want your future to be now postm
military um it's been over six months
now and we we haven't seen any progress
um we've actually seen the opposite
where we've seen him go further into
debt um he hasn't really been able to
keep a steady job um he's been home for
six months and has gone through I think
three jobs already two girlfriends um
doesn't really seem to help out around
the house or contribute to anything um
and just kind of seems to be floating a
little bit so I'm not quite sure what we
should do as parents to help encourage
him I know that he's an adult and I want
to keep our relationship good um but I'm
not quite sure where to go or what to do
from
here there's a couple of things here one
you started the call by saying he
doesn't have fill in the blank he
doesn't have PTSD he doesn't have stuff
from the military he just came home and
then you're watch you're just describing
somebody who's slowly decompensating
right in front of us right this same guy
who accomplished all these things did
all these things is slowly burning
through romantic relationships he can't
keep a job that doesn't sound like your
son
right well he here's the thing he was
like that before so when he graduated
high school we yeah he was like that
before when he graduated high school we
basically gave him a year to figure out
what he wanted to do um and there again
he wasn't keeping a job he was going
from relationship to relationship job to
job okay you know why Bas you know why I
can tell you um my he's one of my good
buddies Dr Henry Cloud um who wrote the
book
boundaries he says it best the reason
your kid your son this boy that you love
isn't doing anything because he doesn't
have
to right he's never had to because your
picture of I don't want to hurt our
relationship is is I don't want to do
anything that makes my son not like
me yeah and those are two opposing
things a parent is often going to spend
significant amount of time not being
liked by their kid and my goal isn't to
be liked by my kid my goal is to raise
an amazing man and I want I want that
35-year-old version of my son that
30-year-old man version of my I want him
to like his dad and that mean the same
way I look back and I not only like I
love coach zo Simpson who pushed me as a
high school kid further than I ever
thought I could go and I accomplished
things on the track under his Leadership
Lessons I still used today mhm and I
love him for that at the time I said
some things about Coach Simpson cuz he's
making me run in that Texas heat right
so um the way Henry Cloud says it and he
says it tongue and cheek but he's
serious is your son's GNA have to get
some
problems he's going to have to get a
very clear set of boundaries you will be
out of my home by this time we love you
so it's okay it's okay for us to give
him an exit date it's not it's not only
okay it's it's not love him you're
watching your son
flounder like what you're doing is not
working and he's going to cuss you he's
going to be pissed he's going to say oh
I needed you this is how you treat me
and you have to say hey U here here's
honestly if I'm in your situation here's
how I would do it you don't have to do
it this way but I would sit down and
take my adult son who's done some pretty
amazing things for himself and for his
team and for his country I would take
him out and say hey
um I went about this the wrong way
and I was really um trying to build a
relationship with you and in so doing I
abdicated some of my parent
responsibilities which is um I never
made you fly I never pushed you out of
the nest and so you gotten real
comfortable here and I like you here you
like being here but it's not the best
thing for you or for us and so at this
date you're out you're out okay oh
you're going to make me homeless oh
you're going to make me homeless you're
no no no no no that's a choice you're
making it's a choice you're making and
if the sun reacts like that John is that
his own fears is that is that truly
anger or is he afraid it's going to be
Terror because for his entire life he
hasn't had to do this that's why I think
I do think it's fair and I know there's
some parents are like all right I'm just
going to start flexing that's that's not
appropriate because it's a bait and
switch you've treated him differently
his whole life but I think it's fair to
set it up and say in 90 days our door
we're going to change locks in 90 days
is time for you to go you got 90 days to
get a job you have to keep going to that
job every day cuz we're not paying any
of your bills zero not cell phone not
car insurance zero you're a grown man
period right yeah and oh so I'm GNA
start it's You' be your fault if I no
it's not it's not and if he needs to get
additional resources for some mental
health challenges he's not telling you
about cool then you can sit with him at
the kitchen table and be with him as he
begins to do the research on those
things now John correct me if I'm wrong
and Anda let me tell you what helps me
in this
situation whenever I don't let my kids
do for themselves what I know they can
do and I want to come in and swoop in
for me I've started to realize every
time I do that it's letting them know I
don't have confidence in them yeah I
don't believe in you I don't believe in
you I don't think you can do this your
own you shouldn't believe in yourself I
don't cuz that's you think you're
helping but ultimately that's the
message you're sending is you can't
right can I can I ask you a hard hard
question Amanda oh of course yes
well I I'm not going to put you on the
spot I just want you to think through
this it's very common for parents doing
the best they can getting their
self-worth their identity that my boy is
home that he's here under my under my
wing I'm still going to look after him
I'm still going to take care of him and
I want you to really internalize this
you cannot use your son to prop up your
identity so his separation him moving
out and heading off into the world is it
going to require you to also do some
work and ask yourself well who am I
going to be now that my little boy is a
grown
man this is the Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
Show
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I am
Jade warshaw this is John deloney we're
taking your calls for the next several
minutes
at least so give us a call the number is
88255 225 and we will chop it up we will
try to give you the best possible advice
about whatever it is you're facing
whether that be in your money in your
marriage in your relationships maybe
even in your career give us a call we
love to do our very best for you uh
let's go to Aaron in Indianapolis
Indiana hi hey how are you Aon good how
are you doing great how can we help
today so um I've been working on the
baby steps over the past few years um I
started kind of right before the
pandemic started um and I'm a nurse so
things kind of got pretty crazy during
all of that um but I started off you
know at that time I had about
$3,000 in debt um and I'm down to just
at 10,000 paid off a pretty good
chunk um I'm a single mom and I've you
know been on my own with him for six
years now and I don't like receive any
child support or anything like that um
it's just me and him and so I was
wondering if somebody has like a big
purchase that's something that they need
to do and they're like following your
plan and not having credit cards and
stuff um I'm like just scraping by so I
don't have a ton of extra that I can
invest in like attorneys and stuff to
try and get child support and get help
how do we like go about paying for
something like that if we don't have
credit card are you scraping by because
your nursing job isn't paying enough or
because you're throwing every less Penny
towards your
debt
um because well I've kind of put paying
off the debt stuff on hold because all I
have left is the student loans um and I
mean that's going to be starting due now
but just straping by just because
um I guess the time that I can work is
when my son's at school so I can't earn
a whole lot of extra um well hold on is
that what are you earning what do you
earn every month so I bring home about
2,500 a month yeah that's not even
here's the deal you're gonna have to
hire some child care for a season MH
because you're not doing that and you
think you're helping your son by having
him with his mom all the time he's not
in school but at the same time your son
is
absorbing the tension of his mom who
cannot
breathe yeah right and so if you took
six months and hired a daycare center
which I know you don't want to do but
they picked him up after school and he
stayed and played and you took six
months and you worked like mad took
every shift you could invited a family
member over to stay with you in the
evening and worked every shift you could
in six months you'd have enough money to
hire an attorney you'd have enough money
you'd be done with this $10,000
nonsense yeah I can't think of a better
job to have right now than a nurse when
I talk when I'm thinking about Mobility
when I think about able to go get extra
shifts and to make money right now I
know that's right you're sitting on a
lottery ticket and if that sounds like
you're paralyzed yeah yeah it does feel
like I am um how old is your how old's
your son he's seven yeah he's seven so
he's in second grade
um and you know I do I do get help from
my parents watching him so that I can
work um so I guess so what you're saying
um and I'm not trying to stick it to you
but you just solved your problem earlier
you said well I can't work the way I
need to because I've got to be home but
you've got your parents there so I kind
of I'm not trying to be hard on you but
I kind of feel like you're looking for
an excuse to not do this and it seems
hard and it will be hard but it will be
so worth it to get out of this and and
and get the money that you need for a
lawyer so that you can start having this
money come in but I mean John and I talk
about it all the time there is going to
be a sacrifice to to in order to make
this happen do you see that yeah and but
it's in your favor yeah and I I I can
see that I guess my resistance to
working extra is just because of I mean
the stress of well let's play that out
you know everything you're stressed
you're stressed right now yeah let's
play that out let's pretend like let's
pretend you do it your way mhm so
tomorrow looks the same the next day
looks the same and you're just getting
more and more stressed there's no
solution if we do it your way right you
just keep making 2500 and you're just
Living on a Prayer hoping nothing goes
wrong you're not getting any child
support that you and the and your son
deserve so if we play it your way
nothing changes it only gets
worse yeah and then the where people get
trapped is you find yourself in the
situation it's scary and it's hard and
then you go sign up with a lawyer and
they put you on a payment plan and now
you're right back in the hole right and
that's definitely something I don't want
to do no here's what we're talking about
we're talking about six months to change
the rest of you and your son's life six
months and I'd sit down with my parents
and say can we make an agreement for six
months I've got to I've got to just slam
the other side of this teeter totter and
get me out of this mess would y'all
commit to picking up my son every day
after school cuz I'm going to drop him
off I want to be mom in the morning I'm
going to drop him off and I'm going to
work doubles for the next 6 months and
every minute I'm not at home when I
could be with my son I'm going to remind
myself that this never happens again in
my family and in his and then you know
what he's gonna be eight and I'll have
mostly forgotten about it yeah he'll
have mostly forgotten about it but he
will know every time mom picks him up
she is laughing her head
off she's smiling she her heartbeat
isn't going 120 M an hour and then
youall go to court and you can smile and
you get the child care or child support
that you
deserve yeah and but we're talking 6
months and it's going to be it's not
going to be fun it's going to be awful
and quite honestly has he become your um
he's become your safe space after all
this hasn't
he um what do you mean safe space I mean
often after a contentious divorce where
Dad just disappears or a single mom that
that little boy can become your whole
world and it might be as painful for you
to work that double it is for your
perception of what he's going to be
experiencing without
Mom I see what you're saying see what
I'm saying so I want to assure you if
your parents are safe and good he's
going to have a blast with them will he
miss his mom oh no question about it but
you're going to have a hard time too and
I want that to just be the fuel in your
jet engine to get out of this mess once
and for all yeah get the gazelle
intensity back and get back into it and
I think
personally uh um you're going to find
yourself in week one exhausted week two
almost crippling exhausted and then week
three and week four you're going to find
the new energy you didn't know you had
and you're going to start serving those
patients who are coming in looking to
you for help you're going to start
staying a little bit taller you're going
to get that 10 grand knocked out you're
going to have 10 grand in the bank and
you're going to tell your supervisor
I'll take any shift you got I'm I'm GNA
take any shift you got and all of a
sudden um you're you're going to start
walking taller right it's these little
bitty winds over time right now you've
got no little winds and it just feels
like everything's compressed on top of
you like one of those heavy anxiety
blankets yeah
exactly yeah so I'd sit down with my mom
and dad and I'd have a hard conversation
not a hard sounds like they're awesome
hey Mom and Dad I'm gonna need you I'm
so blessed and fortunate to have you all
in town because Jade and I talk to God
knows how many people who call and say
hey I got nobody um but you're you're
right there and let's just Hammer this
thing out is it gonna be pleasant fun no
it's gonna be awful and it will change
everything wow
that's something but we talk about that
a lot me there's the sacrifice part and
this isn't just the debt part this is
she got left high and dry she did she
did but there's part of me that's like
and maybe you can fill in the Gap but
we're so focused on what people remember
mentally we we forget about what they
remember in their body their body is
remembering that's right and so often
mom and dad say I can't miss any games
MH because they're going to remember I
was absent and I'm going to say whoo
whoa that kid's going to remember that
you weren't safe uh because every minute
you were around your body was stressed
and so sometimes this the short-term
sacrifice even if it's 2 or 3 years that
six and seven year-old is going to turn
into a 13 and 14-year-old that loves
having a safe place to land let's aim
for that and especially when not by her
hand but in her lap she didn't run this
guy off he left so now she's got to pick
up the pieces let's get it going let's
get it going so good so good this is the
Ramsey
Show
[Music]
all right all right you're listening to
the ramsy show my name is Jade warshaw
Jade W Jade H warshaw joined by
John
R
deloney so this is the time where we
tell America our middle names nope all
right fine I guess you'll never know
we're taking your calls for the next
hour or so the number Dennis that's my
middle name is Dennis is it Dennis no
not really okay then I'm not telling
mine until you tell yours 8825 5225 is
the number all have left Jade it's the
only privacy I got left well now we can
let people go into the comments and take
their best guess again somebody on
reddit's already posted it it's fine oh
that's true yeah don't get into yeah
middle middle initial H is all I'm
saying so do your best all right we'll
take your calls we'll talk about your
life and your money uh but before we do
today's Ramsey Show question of the day
is sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services now that the kids are back
in school let neighborly help you get
things spruced up they're the best place
to find Home Services like Molly made Mr
Handyman and more start your search for
local experts and download the
neighborly app today I'll be doing that
all right today's question comes from
melody in Iowa I'm conflicted on what to
do with my properties after I die I have
two children my son is an alcohol drug
addict and most likely has some mental
illness challenges my daughter's married
has a great husband and two children
currently she she has asked me not to be
a part of her family I divorced I
divorced their father about 15 years ago
and I'm now happily married for 8 years
to a wonderful man my plan was to leave
my rental properties to my children and
that is my dilemma I don't feel that I
want to leave them anything I'd like to
know your thoughts both ethical and
financial thank you oh my goodness
that's a mess that is a mess I'm like
looking through it again um so here's a
couple things that stuck out at me
number one one daughter has said I don't
want you to be a part of my family mhm
mom retold that story and stuck in the
word currently which means she's still
holding out hope she's hoping that this
thing circles back um and that her
daughter forgives her I always like
parents to live in I like all everybody
to live in reality choose reality your
daughters opt it out she said I'm out um
then there's the son the son who's an
alcoholic struggling with all sorts of
addiction it sounds like there were some
significant challenges in this family is
what it sounds like yeah I what comes
across to me immediately
is just because someone is family
doesn't make them uh doesn't mean they
necessarily get all your stuff when you
pass that's number one stuff
cannot duct tape over a whole life of
family trauma no for whatever that might
be right and and so there's thing two
and thing three is like yeah don't the
one who's an addict don't leave them
anything that they can sell to further
their addiction yeah that don't don't
don't contribute to this their struggles
right yeah um she says I don't feel that
I want to leave them anything and that's
my dilemma and I actually don't buy that
because I don't think they'd be right I
don't think she'd be writing I think she
wants to leave them something but
doesn't feel like she can uh and I think
that's funny I interpreted it as she
does doesn't want to leave them anything
and I think that she's beating herself
up as like oh you're a bad mom or you're
a bad like you have this and you're not
going to leave it to him she never says
what everything's worth um yeah and I
don't think I don't know if that matters
I like the I like the philosophical idea
of this so let's I'll I'll give what I
think and then you pit what you think I
I think that
um all parents need to go back to this
idea that they have there's there's no
right thing to do with their money
nobody has automatic right to your money
you get to choose what you do with that
money that's number one so get a get
away get rid of the I have to pass this
no you don't you don't the second thing
is um be very leery of contributing to
somebody who you know is
struggling and sometimes a million
dollars in cash or million dollars in
property can be a millstone around
somebody's neck they're going to Dr true
right number three if one of your kids
says I don't want you in my life mhm
they know you have properties and it's
not worth the money they want you you
left their dad and so as far as they're
concerned you left me too MH you have to
live in that reality which says you now
have to decide who you're going to leave
these properties to you going to sell
them you want to cash them out you want
to put them in a trust just in case yeah
you want to leave him to a friend
there's any number of things but I think
you have to own that reality I'm not
going to contribute to one of my
children who's struggling by giving them
additional responsibilities and
Financial Resources without the proper
support and I'm not going to give this
other kid who's left me like has
divorced me as much as a kid can I'm not
going to give them stuff they don't want
anything to do with me they've left me
yeah right and so I'm going to have to
come up with somebody else or something
else to give this money to I agree I no
John I agree with a lot of what you said
and the only thing I would tag on to
that is just this idea of in her own
words she's like I don't really want to
give him this stuff but maybe I should
and my brain goes to let like being a
cheerful giver and if your heart is not
like I want to do this I feel compelled
to do this um I'm as opposed to just
doing it out of obligation it's almost
like if you're giving out of obligation
if you're giving because you feel like
people are going to judge you if you
don't or whatever that thing even in
your passing don't do it like I feel
like your heart should be in the right
place it should be something that you
want to do that you feel good about
doing obviously not to the son who's the
addict but even to the other child and
that's clearly that piece is clearly not
there it's like take it or leave it so
something I might do is I might um I
have a buddy several men that I trust in
my life that are I've been friends with
for 30 years I might leave them this and
say if and when my son cleans up mhm I
want you to figure out a way to move
this on yeah um if and when my daughter
comes back and shows up at my funeral
and says oh my gosh I miss my
mom let's consider that yeah that's just
an idea it's a great idea it might be
nope I'm moving on I think it's a great
idea I think sometimes people kind of
lock themselves in as it's either this
or that but I'm with a trust you can you
could put so many stipulations in there
and things that have to take place on
down the line and I like that um there's
a lot of control there but in this
case yeah it it kind of needs a lot of
control unless she's just like look
here's there here's a couple Charities
that I've always loved and respected I'm
just going to put this money here or my
local church or you know you have
options it doesn't have to just go to
your family member and their kids you
know there's I'll go find a single mom
who's struggling to make ends meet and
I'm going to gift her a house before I
pass away like whatever it could be any
number of things but this idea I don't
feel like it okay then make your choices
and move on yeah I would I would
definitely say if you're not able to let
me go back again if she's not able to
have a conversation with them esecially
the daughter specifically and say Here's
what I'm planning to do yes or no I
that's your answer yeah that's your
answer yeah and I think that daughter
took that Financial um insight into her
equation and she said my relationship
with you isn't worth these houses I'm
out these properties yeah there's a lot
there's a lot lot going on here and I'm
sorry about that but I've seen it time
and time again where parents with some
sort of assets to leave hold over the
kids oh heck yes and it doesn't surprise
me the kids are like I'm out oh yeah
that's that's the parent that says oh
you did that you're out of the will you
know it's like they can't wait to say
you're dead to me and it's over and it's
like okay well and then you you play
your cards right and it's like well
you're back in the will again and you're
like um okay yeah you
definitely I'm not opposed to having
certain things that should be in place
like obviously you're not going to be an
adct an addict and get money but at the
same time it shouldn't be Ed as a weapon
right right you know that's a big part
of this so the bigger teaching here kids
is love your family well that's number
one and uh make sure you've got a will
make sure you talk to your family about
your will if you've got little kids you
probably if you got little kids or if
you've got just a major net worth you
probably need to trust as well because a
will is not going to do it if you've got
little ones at the house you need to
make sure you've got a trust so that you
can say when they get what you don't
want
an 18-year-old to get $2 million
instantly right kind of cool but no be a
disaster be a disaster I did not make
good choices with the $100 my parents
sent me when I was 18 I would not have
made good choices with $2 million Wow
have you ever inherited money I never
have I never have no I've had a few
family members pass along a gift but no
I've never never inherited a a dime wow
that's my biggest goal a good man leaves
an inheritance to his children's
children and that's how it goes this is
is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
thank you for listening you are
listening to the Ramsey Show thanks for
hanging with us I'm Jade warshaw this is
Dr John deloney uh scripture and quote
of the day for the spirit of God does
not make us timid but it gives us power
love and self discipline discipline
self-control that's what I'm talking
about uh John Wooden says if you don't
have time to do it right when will you
have time to do it over hey that's
something good to think about I love
that uh aa825 5225 is the number Tara or
Tara is in Salt Lake City Utah which one
is
it hey it's Tara Tara I always try to
make it slightly more bougie I'm sorry
Tara Tara makes way more sense
phonetically as well so there you have
it how can we help today hello Tara Tara
I'm okay with Tara too that's fine I can
be bougie yes be
bougie hey um my husband and I are
working the U baby St number two right
now um this time next year we should be
completely debt free aside from our
mortgage um yeah we're excited um but my
husband actually has an opportunity with
his work uh to move to Spain
uh this time next year as well awesome
um yeah and while we're there um his
company would be or his job would be
paying for our
housing um so we wouldn't have um we
would have to really pay for housing and
we wouldn't have um I guess my question
is the mortgage should we does it make
sense to have somebody rent our home
while we're gone knowing that we're only
going to be there for two to three years
uh we do love our home we love the area
that we're in uh so so we do want to
come back to it but also it kind of Mak
sense sell so just sell our home be
completely that free and then put that
Equity that we have in our home to work
while we're in Sp um and come back and
and just purchase a new home when we
actually do come back yeah because
here's a thing there's a couple reasons
why I would go with your latter response
number one is you know you said it's a
year is it exactly one year it it would
actually be two to three years oh girl
yes sell the house number one you'll be
completely debt free like you said and
the next part of this it's a little bit
more kind of out there but when you go
abroad it changes you and if you're
going to be doing that for 2 to three
years when you come back if you come
back you're going to be completely
different people with a completely
different life with a completely
different everything and it's going to
feel weird to move back into a house
that you've had renters in or airbn
beers in or what whoever you've had in
there they've been using your bathroom
they've been you know walking on your
carpet and you're like oh we just had a
whole life in Spain and and then you're
just come kind of coming back to this
old thing you know I think that it would
be really exciting for you to sell the
house be completely debt free you're in
Spain you've got the housing allowance
you can save up money you can come back
and have this whole new life for this
whole new family that you've become does
that make sense yeah that that does make
complete sense and listen to this Tara
Tera Tera Tara Tara Tera three years
ago I was minding my business as ad Dina
students at my dream
University and I just happen to give a
talk to a bunch of parents and
students and an Executive Vice President
of a company was in there dropping her
daughter off and every single part of my
life is different now where I live what
I do the industry I work in my financial
situ every part of my life is
different and so the question we like to
ask here is would you move to another
country and then get online and buy
rental property in Salt Lake City and
rent it out to
strangers absolutely not yeah it would
be insane I would love the idea of you
guys going to another country country
debt-free and just absorbing every bit
of beauty that Spain has to offer oh
yeah I have friends there right now with
their daughter and it's it like I am
just writhing in jealousy as I look at
their pictures or said it's
amazing it's so funny you can go there
completely untethered yeah Tara Tera
look I'll tell you what when my husband
and I moved from South Florida here to
Nashville to take this job we we left
you know we sold our house and it was
kind of painful I mean I was excited to
move here but we had gotten that house
perfectly renovated it was exactly the
way we wanted and part of me had wished
like man I wish we could hold on to this
house and like rent it out and then
whenever we come to South Florida we
could have it and it's there like I had
this thing in my mind and so of course
we didn't do that we sold it moved here
and a couple months later went back to
South Florida drove by the house renters
had been in it because whoever bought it
just rented it right out and immediate
immediately when I looked at said it I
was like oh that's not our house anymore
like it had already taken on the
identity of the people who were renting
and I had already in the six months that
I'd been here at Ramsay I had already
shifted into another mindset and so
going back it was like oh wow that's not
our life anymore we don't live there
anymore um they did something funny with
the lawn and you know all those things
they start to add up so I truly think
that um your life is going to change and
I think that you're going to be so
grateful that you sold this house you
became debt free and then like John said
you're untethered if you want to stay a
little bit longer in Spain who cares or
he'll get an opportunity and you'll go
move to the Netherlands and you'll end
up in Seattle who knows what's gonna
happen yeah that would be awesome I
think that is my big thing is like we we
did buy this home and we fixed it up
just the way we wanted it yeah we have
these these plans in the future that
we're like oh you know when we have debt
free we're also going to do this this
and this and now it's like completely
change and I just feel so emotionally so
attached to the home that I'm yeah it's
hard to let go
that and you're going to get wrapped up
in a the fear of moving abroad there's a
lot of unknowns and even if you're super
excited there's just a ton of unknowns
and sometimes our unknowns look around
our environment and just latch onto a
thing and it becomes all about that
thing that's really not the issue really
it's our body's going ah I'm super
freaked out and kind of nervous then you
should be kind of weirded out to move to
Spain right yeah right that's good
that's part of it be uncomfortable and
go have fun and by the way 3 years from
now will have been through a
presidential election we'll be on the
eve of a senate El you know what's going
to the world's going to look like nobody
knows right nobody knows oh thank you
for the the call Tera Tara and thank you
for letting us have fun with your name
even though your name is Tara which is
better than Tara what say you John
unless you're name Tara then you might
think that name is better than Tara
there there's no Tara I think I might
have made that up I think there's a Tara
well if your name's Tara you're awesome
and you are not the person who called in
the show
today all right uh John deloney do we
want to take one more call or do you
want I just want to chop it up here we
think James we got time let's do it
let's go to Josh Josh Orlando Florida
what's going on hey guys thanks for
taking my call um I'll be quick to the
point um so I make 83k a year and I'm
living paycheck to
paycheck I'm trying to uh solve any any
you know debt I have possible and the
biggest headache I have is I have a auto
loan to where I'm about 15,000 negative
equity shoot and I wanted to figure out
I wanted to find out how do I handle
that negative equity and still uh give
to another vehicle well how much how
much is the car how much do you owe on
the car well the total loan itself
itself is about 31,000 and and what's it
worth if you were to sell it uh it's
about 16 to
17K um honestly in that type of
situation I'd
probably grunted out and P pay it off
yeah write it out I'd write it out
because 31,000 it it's it's it's not
more than half of your take home pay
which is you know what we do is we look
at your annual salary and if we feel
like more you have half or more tied up
in vehicles we definitely tell you to
get out of it at this point you're okay
um and it sucks because you're in debt
and you have to make the payments but
because you're literally half upside
down I I wouldn't even go through the
trouble um I just gr you know grunt it
out what else do you have to pay off um
I got 4,200 in a credit card and that's
it but the biggest thing is is that my
car payment is about 500 and that's the
killer so my uh I can save about 500
bucks a month and I'm trying to save
trying to save more but I'm trying to
look for a way to lower my car payment
yeah I mean that's I mean you did get
into something you're gonna have to work
more you're gonna have to get after it
you're gonna have to pay the PIP you
rolled negative equity I have two two
and a half jobs already but then then
that means they might not make enough
money if you're working two and a half
jobs and you're still not getting there
one of the jobs needs to earn more money
like we need to be
making more than $20 an hour for sure on
the side hustle and that might mean I'm
working the night shift throwing boxes
and does anybody want to do that no it's
tough tough tough work that's for that
might be where the money is yeah you can
tell me you won't do it but don't tell
me you can't do it that does it for this
hour this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to Ramsey
solutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's Ramsey
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started